no i need your listeners to
vote on whether george and i should be a
power couple
power couple in the comedy industry i
heard that you were married well i am
sort of
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg bye oh my
god
smoking the green doesn't have to be
mean
for the smoothest and coldest cannabis
smoking experience you've got to check
out freeze pipe freeze pipe makes a
unique line of freezable pipes bubblers
bongs and more for a chilly smoking
experience you gotta feel the believe
you know a lot of podcasts have these
things and they take ads but i'm gonna
tell you something right now if you're
serious or just starting or if this is
your thing and it's always been your
thing
then please get a freeze pipe do
yourself a favor shop their entire
collection at the freeze
pipe.com and use the code omg high for
10
off find everything from freezable pipes
to bubblers and bongs at the
freezepipe.com
make sure you use the code omg high for
10 off of your entire order but i'm
going to tell you
by looking at the camera i'm going to
tell you
this
makes that experience even greater and
it's already great without freeze pipe
but free pop you'll be like
[Music]
[Laughter]
splash splash i was taking a bath and
noticed i have beautiful balls
our friends at manscape the global
leaders the in below the waist hygiene
are turning men's shower dreams into
their favorite routine with all new
ultra premium premium collection
this all-in-one hygiene skin and hair
bundle is designed to upgrade
everyday man shower routine from head to
toe your skin hair and balls deserve
this save big by going to manscape.com
for 20 off free shipping with the code
omg hi
you know manscape has taken away one of
the few joys i have in my life is the
smell of my own levels when i'm watching
tv
but with all of their products
there's less weight low so there's less
smell and
since i'm not in a relationship i'm
gonna say i enjoy it
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just reminder if you like the show
if you're enjoying the show please like
comment subscribe on any platform you're
checking it out on whether that's on
youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode
excited i started watching her last
night george and then
after five o'clock this morning i got up
to watch her some more she's funny she's
good oh [ __ ] don't tell me yeah
goddamn i was i was excited i was
looking forward
you know
when [ __ ] get
into the rarefied air
you know
two questions can a young guy be a old
[ __ ] too or can just a old
[ __ ] be an old [ __ ] no a
young guy can be a old [ __ ] and
can be boring
yes okay young guys there's some young
guys like that too
and then there's all guys who are
eternally young you know
you know gill
loves comedy has a great laugh
uh
you know um
he's always loved comedy he's gone to
see shows he loves comedians
he loves the beard he you know how much
he loves comedy he goes and sees momo
[Laughter]
you got to be a fan of some he's a
friend
he's a great supportive friend that's
right that's the kind of friend you want
but i but he is uh
he's a great uh person a lot of heart
and
that's the first before we start this is
mike this is a gift for you
from me and a gift
yeah when you grow up poor i'm gonna
tell you this
this case
if if i was eight years old and i found
this case in the street car that's a
bathtub that's a plane
i put
my
marbles in there
then as i got older a condom
some of my grandmother's pills
all in here this would be like you know
those dudes carry those straps like a
man bag
when you're poor this is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] is you're like hey where's your
birth certificate take it easy hang on
i'm getting it yeah you know you put it
in there anything that's
this smooth
velvety is it so
thank you for being on the show
and
thank you for being
cranky one of them oh this is so perfect
oh my hands are sweating cool oh this is
so perfect oh george
oh these are beautiful
oh my god
those are great
god damn
i hope those two [ __ ] jeans don't
fall off i just glued them up
well i'll put them back
wait a minute hold on hold on
that
yes honey you know that
is
[ __ ] swag and swole all of
them
league to the queen of comedy
go
that [ __ ] goes
that's all you all a hundred percent of
the time that that you know when you see
something that looks like a person and
you're like
well how much
what are the glasses right there oh
these are
these are i said all right i'm gonna
take this okay you know what cracked me
a bit look let me tell you something
which pertains to this
many years ago george and i were in a
bar late at night
we were drinking tequila which is my
it's like something something's gonna
happen and the bar was closed and the
bar is closed and i made them reopen it
back up and they once they realized who
george was and you know we got to go in
my little team his
and it was great as the tequila
flowed i think that we kissed right i
think we did it was amazing either he
can kiss her i can once
i thought for a minute i said wow what
if we were some kind of power couple for
one moment i fantasized let's say that's
a bad [ __ ] i have no hack my
goddamn self what if we could make some
[ __ ] like this happen and as soon as
that thought came it left because alas
did not happen i went through the
quarantine alone as did george
we could have been locked up together
damn
[Music]
you could have had those glasses a long
time ago you know
you know the queen
the queen is really just
a person
that was born under the reign of the the
monarchy so she's the queen you take a
night other 95 year old woman without
that bloodline
and she's just a 95 year old woman
but the queen is the queen no matter
where you see them no matter what
they're doing and no matter what age
she would be
to me because i've met everybody in this
business a queen 100 of the time like
from a monarchy of comedy that has very
few members
she is the queen of comedy and i love
that you're not afraid of anything
either
well you know
i mean i'm afraid of a lot of things at
least i can still give into it yes and
that's why i only watch myself once
and then i don't watch myself anymore in
any project or in any show and i don't
like studying myself and [ __ ] because i
feel like if i do
it'll it might i might get
self-conscious of the free [ __ ] that i
am and i might start to say god damn i
don't want to do that number one that's
the very [ __ ] that make me different and
who i am is
is that closer to my mind
i really like salt and lemon you know
the way this my old
boyfriend taught me
um
this is gerbia right yep there's a lot
of places to start and you want to know
let me tell you about the power of
manifestation of my mind
so earlier today
i was driving down
crenshaw to be specific and i passed my
eyeglasses place and i said boy should
you need some new glasses because
everything i have mostly is shades and i
said i need some black
glasses that's what i said today
look how god works and then
as i was coming here i never ever ever
ever drink beer unless i'm around my
mexican friends and [ __ ] like that and i
said damn i wish i had a beer in there
today i swear to you
i said it when i was turning on mariposa
and i said wish i had a [ __ ] beer and
i said i'm gonna tell george i never
drink beer unless i'm around my essays
and look at this this is the power
this is the power of people you can
speak [ __ ] into existence that's why i'm
speaking into existence um that i want
to be the next black female in late
night you know i'm tired of this [ __ ]
i'm tired tired of the [ __ ] snow
storm and late night like i'm ready to
shake this [ __ ] up they've had black
women in late night before they have
monique her show what wasn't to my
liking and then they had robin feedy and
i was so uninterested i didn't even give
it a chance i'm made for this [ __ ] i'm
not made for daytime i'm not made for uh
cooking segments and how to make a
christmas wreath out of toilet tissue
roast that's not me i want to do some
[ __ ] like what hef used to do playboy
after dark
boozy and laid back with with with
talented people just
you know swimming in and out and maybe
alicia key might be on the keyboard that
day and you know i got ideas uh um if
you want to produce it let's talk about
it i think uh i think that sounds like a
pretty good idea that's great yeah i got
it all worked out i got dancers i got
the whole [ __ ] but hugh hefner wasn't
hugh hefner was a host of playboy after
dark but he wasn't a comedian
no he wasn't but they would sit around
and they would smoke and they would just
have comedians on and he would have
comedians on
and it's almost like performing in and
you're living yeah you know when i was a
little boy around six years old i was
put to sleep at an apartment on hubbard
in san fernando and when i woke up i
walked into the living room where there
was a party going on and my mom was
dancing without her top on it on the
coffee table in the middle of the room
you saw that for real so i don't think
i'm going to try to do a late night show
where there's
[Laughter]
well i've already done
all of that stuff as we were speaking up
i loved it i've watched stuff that i saw
today
it was good stuff he saw my penthouse
spread he was yeah i saw the pen house i
told him i also had been a lingerie
ambassador for rihanna with her savage x
fenty lingerie
line
and so
i'm not
uh if i did get on the [ __ ] coffee
table and dance if it's my show and it's
late and i'd give some fun you know they
got me with dictators hanging out
dancing where do you see where would you
see a show like that going and you know
well you know i had a late night show
you know yeah george and i i was a i was
a
faithful watcher he used to come out to
[ __ ] low rider
and um where do you see where do you see
a show like yours well b-e-t
more streaming comedy central i think
it's got to be a streamer uh and then
there's that because of course to be
100 authentic and who i am we would have
to you know stream it but
uh the goal would be to you know maybe
uh do things a little different on
regular network tv if it's [ __ ] late
night maybe i don't want to be on
channel 87 or you know some subscription
thing maybe there's somebody shout out
about so go ahead on it just let it it's
[ __ ] late night the kids ain't
supposed to be up you ought to be able
to have some freedom they say all that
[ __ ] on the rap music stations or
anything that i would say they say all
that [ __ ] in [ __ ] videos any
[ __ ] thing i would say
so what the [ __ ] who's scared they are
okay can i tell you something i've been
around tv for the last 20 years yeah
with the last two minutes that you said
[ __ ] you know you're gonna be on
network on that [ __ ] like that
they won't let you they won't let you do
anything that's risque
they won't let you yeah you used to be
able to
and you know johnny carson actresses
came out with no bras on and all that
[ __ ] i've seen a girl on carson
uh some blonde that used to be on their
regular she had a cat in her lap
and carson said boy would i like to pet
that [ __ ]
okay
you said it
i saw you i mean
i think it's a i think it's a great idea
in concept but
well when the network starts reality
that's when my bubble gets burst i think
i think in that
i mean listen where would you put it
let's just talk hypothetically i would i
would put it on a streaming service
which one hbo max
yeah i would stream amazon
you [ __ ] with them uh i have a
relationship with them all right you
have a relationship with them i have a
lot of [ __ ] on them
tuesdays on prime would they find it
though if you want to watch it yeah
you talk about it once a week like bill
maher
once a week allows you to do all the
other stuff that you do doesn't you
don't really worry about booking gas
you can get somebody you know people
more reliable once a week than than four
times a week
once a week
is a grind too is uh yeah you're there
saturday night live you know they're
there all week but you're there all week
but
you know sure yeah okay would you say my
weed party is a bit like playboy after
dark yes
it's beautiful you you've been to my
weed party
yeah it's great it's very much who were
you digging at the wee party well i
[ __ ] up because eddie van halen was
there and i didn't know who the [ __ ] it
was i didn't see him he was gray i
didn't know it was him and i'm like how
the [ __ ] could i be at the same goddamn
party as eddie van gaal and bigger
vampire fan as i've been
and uh not know that so i was pissed
about that who did i see at your party
that was really exciting well you
and um
the band the band was great [ __ ] band
and look the caterers
ed asner was there already two drinks
i'm already big to the names lou asner
was there right lawrence fishburne you
were with
you couldn't get away from him you guys
were very close for a couple hours sid
and anthony oh gina rodriguez all the
girls were great [ __ ] smoking ass
party
george and i really missed you during
the um
quarantine we talked a couple times
kept a pretty close watch on each
other's ids and stuff and that's good
here is something that i have created
called sanasana
uh it is a vix type rub with cbd and thc
and i know that you have some pains
occasionally i had double knee
replacement surgery total both new knees
i'm making the [ __ ] stallion
don't get it [ __ ] up
but i still love you know
[ __ ] for your shoulders and oh it's good
can you talk about how
can you talk about the knee replacement
surgery yeah i'll talk about anything
did you start to feel it on the road and
start to feel it when you're standing up
when you're traveling
totally when i was stand up for too long
i went to doing stand-up sit-down like
mooney used did it go to your hips did
it go to your head no no hips on life
they they're doing fine
you got that
no but it was my god
thank you
you know you can't be [ __ ] trying to
get your legs up in the air no my legs
go up in the air my hips are fine with
my
yeah yeah okay so so then you start to
know that you're you're and that's real
pain now what happened with my sister
uh is a nurse she
had a knee surgery but she's just a
regular person she didn't post
the therapy that she did yeah and i knew
that she had said her needs a certain i
told her my knees was hurting and
so
the next thing i knew she was out back
with the grandkids and [ __ ] and i said
well [ __ ] if that's the result you got i
said maybe i'll come to texas where she
lives
and
i want the same [ __ ] surgeon you had
and all that and i flew to texas and my
sister took care of me breakfast lunch
and dinner for like eight weeks you do
um the surgery i thought you know you
lay up in the hospital enjoy your
medication for a couple of days don't
get your black ass up and you are
walking the same day
just maybe a step or two okay and then
you you go home now i had excellent
aftercare somebody came monday wednesday
and friday to my sister's house for
three weeks then i had to do monday
wednesday friday for four weeks uh uh
outpatient therapy like the hospital gym
and after by that time you know after
that i was doing stairs and all this i
did talk like all that [ __ ] but if you
don't have your aftercare and if you
don't do your afternoon
and if you don't have anybody to help
you you about to be [ __ ] cause you're
not gonna want to do nothing but eat
take your meds and sleep and if you
don't bend and exercise your leg you're
gonna get froze there like that that
scar tissue starts forming quick
i've had both of them replaced okay the
first one and then at one point in time
during therapy
they make made me get up on a table and
your legs like that but you have to be
able to eventually straighten it out oh
i did it in the bed so the therapist
would come
and push all of his weight
and it's the most painful thing i've
ever been through
and i sat there and i laughed
and the guy on the table next to me as a
therapist walks away says how can you
laugh
i said because i was too embarrassed to
cry
you know he did that now when i did the
second one
i went in there and as soon as i got up
on the table he says okay big boy you
know what's next i got up on the table
and my leg was flat straight flat he
said no no no how'd you do that
i said it's amazing what pain will do
for you
i remembered the pain that i went
through here from coming out of the
hospital started therapy
so when i got out of surgery waking up i
started working that knee right now
because i was still medicated oh yeah
yeah the block because you get a block
yeah so now but are you supposed to be
moving it after yeah yeah yeah that was
wow
still while it's still yeah yes yes
the more you do the better when i got up
on that table
did they tell you did they tell you what
was going to go into the knee
replacement no and
all your friends tell you don't watch it
on youtube until you've had the surgery
which i didn't i didn't watch it till
afternoon no you you now you get your
knees they kept
you you're not laying straight they got
your knee bent like that and cut that
[ __ ] open like that
and then so you don't want to know
nothing about that sorry sorry
spoiler alert
nobody might be getting ready
the guys that do the pros
okay started with it they referred me to
a guy that had
done all of his residency and all of his
training through kernel joke
i then go ahead and go down there
and he's the one that did it for me damn
yeah but what about your man see my
sister i didn't take my nurse well you
are you and jesus well can you bring
them next week though i take everything
they give me bring that [ __ ] i'll take
them you know why i didn't think man i
learned real quick you take that that
[ __ ] for pain
and you can't [ __ ]
oh it didn't you know yeah yes now
that's you know i wasn't going to go
there
you know
but
you do get
like a muffin elvis died when he was 42
on august 16th
and
he hadn't [ __ ]
since that
special nbc where he wore the black suit
that was 69.
he went all those years with that [ __ ]
talking about being blocked [ __ ] out the
chalk from for schools public schools
talking about [ __ ] blocks
had pills in his intestines that hadn't
even died dissolved yet that's great wow
he had like chalk like little kids make
smiling like stars okay
elvis
okay
would you recommend it for somebody that
needed knee replacement [ __ ] yeah yeah
don't be a pump but that'll be a problem
but it does hurt
well i mean it hurts the work hurts the
surgery don't hurt you ain't gonna know
nothing about the surgery but uh later
maybe two days later when the block
wears all the way off right i i didn't
have i never took anything for pain when
i'm i have a high i i have a high
painkiller i've had a child and so [ __ ]
that
i had to give it a shake i had a lady
that was next to me in therapy said
anybody that says having a child is the
worst pain there is is wrong knee
replacement
that [ __ ] is a little bit was a lot
tougher than having a baby honey you're
gonna grab some
yep it's the best thing i ever did you
know that gary gary monroe who toured
with dl
fry his security guy was a police
officer
and he was he lives in baltimore and he
came to go he came to see us baltimore
in the fourth season in baltimore out
there by the river and
when he got up
he
he said that knee surgery was so much
pain for him
that he wouldn't wish it on his enemy
now maybe that's the doctor that he had
because different doctors have different
that has a lot to do with the two
because i was sent home with an ice
machine thing because this was an ice
and i said and elevated and i was sent
home with a thing but these doctors some
a lot of people get in they they their
doctor don't send them home yeah they
didn't send me home [ __ ] oh no honey i
had a whole iphone they sent a therapist
out to my house yeah and i called the
doctor i said get rid of this guy this
guy ain't [ __ ] you know he wasn't doing
anything for me a little thing on the
floor pedaled this thing it wasn't doing
anything for i said i need to get into
it but i don't want to make this the
geriatric bad knee [ __ ] show
you know let's talk about something else
no but i mean i'm aging myself i'm
trying to get a man and not run one away
[ __ ] can't even can i tell you can i
tell you a story of
you know i love prescription drugs
so when i was having my kidneys and i
had a stent in there i didn't know what
a stent was
so a stent is a piece of wire they use
to keep your ureter open
so i had two of them i had one in each
kidney after my transplant yeah yeah
and then i went to my urologist
and he took he was i was laying on the
table and he had this long ass thing and
i said
okay well what's happening there and he
gave me some local solution on my penis
had a clip on it the girl was holding my
hand
yeah and he put that camera down the
hole of my penis of your dick went in
there in your bald sexes pass my balls
past bananas boulevard right next to his
pizza
prostate glass personnel
all the way up towards
bakersfield by sacramento up here
the 49ers
put that camera in my penis it went all
the way up to silicon valley like
well
and how much of the wire had to go in
this one
i was holding on to the thing the girl
had never been so uncomfortable then i
had to get the other one out and when i
took the other one out i took a bike it
in at five i took half at six and then
another half at seven i went there and
they gave me solution you could have
driven a mini cooper with both doors
open
[Laughter]
out of my dick
and i wouldn't have felt you could have
left the gas pump in there
i wouldn't have felt [ __ ] i said well
you ain't catching me
off guard twice
i didn't feel anything he goes well
we're done and i said now i got the rest
of the day to burn off really five and a
half years i know what's crazy about
that
since we're still on the thing is that i
had a catheter which i had always said
in my whole entire life i'd say how the
[ __ ] do they get a catheter in a in a
little pee hole right and i'm like i
mean it's it's just the concept i've
never understood that i'm like is it
right is it smooth at the end surely
it's not like a i don't know but anyway
i woke up i had one in in me
and so from the knee surgery so then
they said well we're gonna have someone
come up here and remove your catheter
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is it gonna
hurt what's gonna happen then a big old
i was got my [ __ ] in texas big ol fine
ass white boy like you came through the
[ __ ] door i threw them legs up
so goddamn white i was like okay baby
give me that
not necessary i'm like i don't know well
[ __ ] well how are you going to do it he
said it's really
encountered three and he did some [ __ ]
and i guess a bubble popped in my [ __ ]
oh god how did we get on this [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] joy
was your air was it air or did you do it
no there's a bubble they put the hose in
your little field did you do anything
they blow a bubble inside so it don't
fall back out you pee i was like blowing
the kids
i'd rather have a real traditional kiss
bone on my [ __ ] than that
and it sounds like a pop it sounds like
a pop
it was kind of you know i felt a little
something i mean
let me you know how they make those
commercials where they send catheters to
your house how the [ __ ] can you
it's almost like stabbing yourself you'd
be like
you know
those [ __ ] things they put they put
them on that and hold on hang on you
guys i'm just going to change my
catheter
makers are the smoothest hitting pipes
and bongs around
today's episode is brought to you by
freeze pipe each freeze pipe product
uses freezable glycerin chambers that
cool smoke by hundreds of degrees
pop one of these glycerin chambers in
the freezer for one hour and smoke
passes through the icy chamber it's
instantly chilled for a bigger colder
and smoother hit man
listen why
why be smoking at room temperature where
you can take yourself to the freeze
zones okay eight
putting ice on your bong is one thing
but
it takes it
putting ice in your bong is one thing
but it's time to take the training
wheels off
and enjoy massive clouds
with zero throat or chest burn man
no true listen i'm gonna take i used to
do needlepoint i'm gonna need to point
that on a pillow in my house
a massive cloud sigh
massive clouds with zero throat or chest
burn on two pillows i'm gonna use in my
room
uh scientifically engineered to
outperform traditional pipes freeze pipe
offers a luxury smoking experience
at every day great prices and you know
what
this is um very true you know i think
when i have my whole wheat in the pool
party
i'm gonna have everybody
uh try freeze pipe because uh it's
awesome it's easy to use
when you smoke it and it's cool it's
just like nothing you've ever done
before and i would recommend it
to
marijuana's everywhere
it says friends but i think marijuana's
is the better
there you go my grandma thought
everybody was a marijuana anyway so i
might as well say
i'll recommend it to marijuana's far and
wide
if you're tired of burning throats or
coughing too much when you light up
visit the freezepipe.com and use code
omghi for 10 off that's the
freezepipe.com use code omg hi for 10
off and say goodbye to harsh
cannabis smoke but say fast because that
smoke disappears quick
let me walk you through the manscape
shower routine
step one
lather on the cologne infused ultra
premium body wash and aloe vera sea salt
to keep your skin
feeling clean and moisturize all day
not sure if you heard the correct but
the body wash is cologne infused so that
special someone in your life
will absolutely love it listen if a
girl's going down there and she smells
like just
[ __ ] gotchoi that's all she's gonna
smell every time but you could you could
be [ __ ] clean down there as [ __ ]
superman i'll just smell your old
[ __ ] ball
ball
step two
the hair care time apply the two in one
shampoo plus conditioner
that cleanses and nourishes in one step
the non-greasy formula has a base of
coconut water green tea
also
turmeric and sage
apply this to your armpits and public
region too
good now leave it in
step three once you hop out of the
shower
protect yourself from body odor by
applying on the manscape aluminum free
deodorant this deodorant dries clear and
is also cologne infused
step 4
have tattoos or dry skin let's hit your
skin with hydrating body moisture spray
step 5
apply the manscape lip balm
this is a free gift when you purchase
the ultra premium collection
last but not least we're using the
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer to clean
off any unwanted body hair the lawnmower
4.0 is waterproof so you can bet it's a
major key to the new shower routine
absolutely no question the elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your balls might look like
punching bags i know might do but rocky
too don't treat them like one and
benefit from their proprietary skin care
technology the new bundle will change
your life and want all my listeners out
there to live their best lives and
listen
uh
manscaped from the time that we've been
doing this podcast i've used the
products and
it's been uh
because i would one of my jokes was
don't get old because you won't like the
way it smells but manscape has helped me
be less odorous even though nobody's are
going down there i'm going down there
and listen i've been going down there
for 60 years this is the best i've ever
smelled down there
forget about little league when i
control it all over but
there's been damage down there
but
i can say manscape has helped me get
that new car smell back again get 20 off
and free shipping with the code omg hi
at manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code omg hi at
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscape
shower routine and i would think this
would be a great gift for
any time especially but father's day
coming up or whatever it's one just
thing
easy to uh
to to get
question
i've been watching this series called
secrets of the playboy mansion yes
i've been there once i've been there
yeah i was kind of asking how many times
have you been
i've been there i've been there twice to
the mid-summer eve's party oh oh
yeah
that's the big big big one those girls
were like airbrushed bikinis but they
were really nice right right right right
more funny when i went there for some
mma [ __ ] but it was still a nice
party it was a pajama party
the girls were naked half was out there
with his girl half yeah yeah took a
picture with half have you seen the
series yes
is a new one tonight every monday it's
[ __ ] guilty what do you think about
that
i think it's all true
i think he did it was super powerful
because everybody of influence came
there to get their [ __ ] rocks off the
perverted hollywood [ __ ] and i
think that they're true if you got a
bunny on your shirt and you go to the
police and say [ __ ] martin scorsese
just tried to ram me in the ass with a
uh
a rake and be like [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here and so that's because of
other cases of other [ __ ] i've been like
why'd a [ __ ] wait 30 years but in this
case i think that even when his ass was
old and alive he still had a lot of
influence and if you talked about this
[ __ ] you could get [ __ ] why did
somebody wait 30 years
well i don't know because i've been
raped and i told immediately just nobody
gave a [ __ ]
wait a minute no
i got raped by three white boys first
time i ever had sex with one of them
live across the street from me when i
lived in castro valley california you
know who you are and you and you never
yeah well i i cut school
with these boys we wasn't drinking beer
i don't think i don't remember maybe
that's a disclaimer and to be able to
cope with stuff like this this is where
the humor comes in you have to be able
to laugh about it or maybe you can't
move that was the first time you ever
had sex yeah
so i go back to the school like they
jumped over you know their handle it
wasn't like you know i mean this was
clearly like rape it was three guys wow
it wasn't like they had no technique we
was in like junior high or something
like that i went to all white schools in
castro valley i was just born in
arkansas and until i was in elementary
school lived in oakland yeah then went
to got educated in casper valley and
hayward and then moved back to oklahoma
then l.a so
i go back to school i go to class i'm
just sitting there but my hymen
technical term have been broken saw
blood in the chair so the teacher saw it
so she's like what the [ __ ] happened so
i told her what happened so he took me
to the office and i called my parents
and i called the police but it was
really i was adopted so it's really my
step
father
slash uncle who married my aunt who was
my father's anyway that
so we got home
like like we told the police report got
home and the alcoholic stepfather
stayed up and wouldn't let me go to
sleep and he was drinking and wouldn't
let me go to sleep and berated me how i
was about to ruin the boy's life and
made me go back to the police station
and recant the whole ship are you
serious
you think i could make up a lie like
that on the spot i'm good no no no no
wow
but you know what
um all that is in me somewhere
that'll probably come out of my academy
award award-winning performance because
i have always wanted to be one of them
people in a in a room with a bat where
you could just bust bust all this [ __ ]
up in the room yeah people do that i i i
really need to do that
but that's where you know the sacrifices
your mental health
or good comedy
you know
you know you take that [ __ ] yeah you can
flip it that's not my advice for people
to do but if you're a natural-born
comedian like me george so you were
adopted you didn't know your mother or
your father yeah i knew my mother but my
father was murdered when my mother was
pregnant with me wow by her brother my
uncle
uh-huh fun facts people put this down in
the trivia book we went from [ __ ]
knee surgery to
great what the [ __ ] is this show up but
you know but but with fun facts
they don't have to be all good good
facts i mean you could have fun and now
but the thing with that the thing with
that is you is is that
you
it it's it's those things aren't planned
but then they they're [ __ ] with you
the rest of your life oh of course like
that like like your mom or your friend
did the school no your rabbi [ __ ]
molest you or when your [ __ ] uncle
wants to give you a [ __ ] bath or when
you make your kids sit on somebody like
that the kid don't really like sit there
laugh on i don't force that [ __ ] i never
ever in my
life my daughter's 26 let nobody babysit
her who who had a a brother right or
something like that my one girlfriend or
her girlfriend didn't have didn't have a
bedroom do i had a brother the minute i
found that out no more over yeah and i
also know this because i am a survivor
person
that when you look at kids you look at
the school picture you said sparkle in
their [ __ ] eye
that's still what hope looks like you
know before they get tainted and jaded
by life
but when something like that happens to
a boy or a girl that light that light
goes out and their eyes become like
shark eyes and they're just too the eyes
are too grown for their age and that's
when you know something i'm lucky to say
that like never went out of my daughter
and she told me nothing never happened
to it if that's that if i die tomorrow
and i accomplish that
then i feel great okay
did people in the school know
did it become no because you know
remember i'm at a white school there's
only like three four black kids there
man
but there's no biggie anymore you know
i wish somebody raped me now god damn
huh in a while
[Laughter]
yes but but
but how did you get from like where you
were born in arkansas
it almost looks like toilet
toilet towelette towelette did they say
toilet arkansas people
because they look
t-o-i-l-l-t-o-l-e-t-t-e looks like
listen if you were gonna [ __ ] with where
somebody was from
you might as well say like cool
california
but that's
but that's toilette i saw it i said you
know everybody's gotta be like toilet
arkansas i mean people tease you all
your life about that you know they say
you're from toilet arc yeah yeah yeah no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so it's toilet
and population like 235 probably like
today how did you how did you how did
you get west how did you end up going
west so when my father got murdered and
my mother had seven kids already was
pregnant with her eighth
my father's sister my aunt
my i think those were the devils in the
family the ants no that's me i'm an
auntie i think they were though i think
they would be like don't take that from
him on fire goddammit cats are better
than their parents all the time i i'm a
great aunt and so anyway um
my aunts my dead father's sister
begged uh her
my mother her and and and and my other
other aunt were all pregnant at the same
time yeah these two aunts lost babies
couldn't have no more kids only my mom
had the kid she's already stressed and
whatever i don't know they they look at
you you look at this george not me oh
[Music]
and
yay
so anyway uh she said you know let me
help you out you got enough going on
blah blah blah let me take the baby
brother in some kind of way an adoption
happened and i got brought to california
now did i want to grow up with my
brothers and sisters for in arkansas yes
yeah did i want to be alone
with a predator by myself
no but had my life not turned out this
way would i be doing what i'm doing now
you would not no so god don't make no
mistakes we just have to
go along with the program now i think i
read where you when you first started
you were like on the talk show or
something like it's a radio show and no
it's a a show called the sobe television
network is a network in oakland
california ran by chuck johnson who had
uh all black owner operated television
station before b-e-t oh yeah and he had
it in oakland he was one of the first
people probably the first who was who
was on those shows like mark curry used
to do it
hammer and elliot hammer and laura hayes
and uh myself and then when they had a
thing in oakland called the bay air
black comedy competition so
when the comics would come from out of
state to come to
oakland to be in this community where
was that at the paramount at the
paramount that's where the finals were
then when they would come to oakland
they would come on my show so that's how
i ended up knowing a lot of la comics
and comments from how to say when i came
to l.a you know i it's really that's
what i was going for yeah uh so
you did that
and then can you sing too or
just yeah i sang i did um musical
theater for years before i ever did
film and television um and so you know
i'm from that area where you got to be
triple threat you got to be able to sing
dance act you know do something like
that i don't i don't i don't dance that
much no mo but it's not like i can't
because we got new knees right there all
right that's right i don't dance no more
i saved myself for you know did you find
your did did you find your brothers and
sisters no they always did let me know
who they were so i always did visit and
have a relationship with them but you
know you gotta look at seven brothers
and sisters that's
not doing so well and struggling in
arkansas
you're my happy california with a
suitcase full of little short sets and
barrettes and sandals matching and [ __ ]
they won't slap the [ __ ] out of me i'm
sure but you know that if you stayed
back there you wouldn't be here no i'd
be in a trailer somewhere but it's tough
it's tough to leave like you you know
it's tough to leave a place
who still they just they
they can't leave
that's
but you know what it's hard to leave
places where you're the [ __ ] and go
somewhere where you ain't nobody right
that's really hard you know if you live
somewhere and you got credit at the
grocery store you know the cleaner they
know your mama gets your nails done all
this and then you got to go somewhere
you don't know nobody and you don't know
[ __ ] from china right then you got to
learn what north east south and west is
in l.a that's just confusing you can go
to [ __ ] north la brea you take
your ass down to south debra it's a
difference
the uh uh
you know
we're talking about about half you know
like
in
i think maybe that's you know the the
hugh hefner family is not involved with
playboy anymore that's what the
disclaimer is the disclaimer
and the playboy jazz festival didn't
come back after the pandemic and i think
maybe a little bit has to do with
that
series uh on
playboy it does not mean
it doesn't make sense yeah probably
probably you know probably uh it's a
good time to shut it down did you did
you see the
uh documentary on showtime about bill
cosby
but you weren't on it
no but i have pictures
did they ask you to be honest no
never in my they asked me to be on i
said no
never in my
career
have i ever been sexually approached by
anybody about anything my mouth too big
my attitude too [ __ ] up and they're
like i don't need the trouble with this
[ __ ] i can go [ __ ] with this [ __ ] over
here not that [ __ ] loud now [ __ ] and
plus she said snitch and she tells me i
get that i can see that so i've never
never not one time ever it's actually
the opposite i'm surprised some cases
haven't been found on me
yeah
uh but you knew but some people knew
about
some things like that right about what
cosby
a lot of people knew you can't do
nothing without an accomplice nobody the
only person
like i didn't know i didn't know him
personally till
like 2010 but
in seeing some comedians in the back
back in the day like in the 90s or 80s
there was talk about
i don't think it was drugging though but
just
like getting head before shows and stuff
like that oh yeah i don't know who
doesn't want that
[Laughter]
i had a thong in my [ __ ] golf bag for
like seven years
it's like somebody put in a banana
yeah um
but it's a it's a it's a business where
you know
uh
it's never easy i must say it's never
easy
stand up it's never easy to travel
it's never easy to go to a town and be
at the [ __ ] mercy of a [ __ ]
fire next door to the club or nobody's
going
or
[ __ ] some [ __ ] that's gonna happen
during the time
we do uh we do a really good thing right
now while um
i'm on tour with kat williams right here
and um first of all there's several
groups of us who knows transportation
isn't it is cat still wearing like a
parker in the hot day or is he he's a
[ __ ] pup and he can where what
the [ __ ] no i don't know he can't but he
looks good and all that [ __ ] yeah you
know from time to time between
he's very very well styled i mean i'm
impressed every week
and i like that pimp [ __ ] so you know
but but um
the the fun thing that we do is there's
a group of us that you know just get an
airbnb and then we just stay together
and we just um what'd you call uh
instacart
yeah yeah sure and just cook and we all
get along and we're all kicking nobody
never sees us because we're not in the
hotel yeah
that's pretty good so so how long has
the tour been on maybe for like the la
since last summer about six man and how
is it
it's delicious it's amazing what were
you what was the last what were the last
shows you guys did
roanoke virginia and
the coliseum there greenville south
carolina
i think we go to cincinnati or something
like that this weekend mm-hmm a lot of
markets that are not what you may call
mainstream but they got big arena that's
right and other people like we never get
nothing down here we're so [ __ ] glad
i took pictures when we was in roanoke
my fans like had um
nails through their lip and [ __ ]
you know and i was like yeah this is
this is all good because that's what
comedy is supposed to do well you know
that band kiss would go to chicago
and go to all the main cities and then
they would go
to like you know
off outside and ride florida yep i did
that out in the
in cedar rapids in des moines listen
they they they they don't have a lot to
spend the money on right they got money
they deserve comedy too they're super
grateful they're excited i like when i'm
on social media now like before the show
and you can see people in their story
like on our way to see the hour date
night and all that i'm like yeah and
then you know you can always tell the
bible to what you know i'm like fifth to
go on so by then i don't heard what
what's working for who and what not to
over the thing in a room and i come
but i just you know i love what i do
sometimes that's the only place you feel
good is there sometimes
yes uh and what is do all the comics
stay on time
excuse me yes because we're
professionals
all right
and we have a time
if somebody goes over is there a penalty
uh yeah
not for us
but you know like as the show goes over
ultimately that's
the first comedy get down we did on the
road
charlie was supposed to do 20 minutes he
did 40.
and that sent everything crazy and then
we had to get i had to talk to we all
had to talk to him because you know we
were we were the 30 guys he was at 20.
you talking about when you guys did yeah
and then we told him to which i showed
up about five times yeah and we told him
to watch the time and he's like oh man i
didn't know i went over
i do not like or respect
somebody who disrespects the clock
these shows are on time just like in the
theater i came to the theater first
so i'm disciplined you know i worked for
sheena easton
at the at bally's i was with 30 minutes
i got off in 27
and the next night i saw a little dude
there and he said walks up to me goes
hey man
last night you didn't do 30 minutes i
said yeah i did he goes
no you didn't you did 27. it's 27 30 i
said no
is 31 30 i said no
what's 30 30. tonight dude 30. i never
saw him again
and i did 30. i never saw him again he's
like [ __ ] do your time damn
30 is 30. yes i mean you know especially
when you're in vegas it's very
structured period they're going to start
on time period they're going to be out
on time too yeah they know everything
because there's union they got to pay
their security and all that [ __ ]
they're not [ __ ] around you know even
at these theaters
it's like it used to be a thousand
dollars a minute a few 15 minutes over
the show
yeah
15 thousand dollars out your ass
for the people listening not watching
i'm shooting an almond
that's what my
can we talk about
can we talk about how how did the whole
thing with borat uh how did you get that
part first of all that movie the first
one even the second one
you seen them i can only talk
i mean you can talk on the first one the
first one caught everybody off guard
because
everybody thought that even
even you yeah
you thought that guy was a real guy no i
just didn't know what the [ __ ] i had
signed up for right yeah okay
yeah i mean you know okay so
i didn't even have a car
i got an audition call who told your
agent called you
[Music]
and said they need somebody who can
improv well
with somebody who can come and um be
like a hooker
at a fancy dinner party and
tell some like wild hooker stories
it's a dress like a hooker
well you haven't seen it like it is uh
iconic it was plastic it was nominated
for academy awards it's [ __ ] iconic
i mean and nobody knew
what the [ __ ] it was what the [ __ ] it
was i didn't even had never even heard a
word
borad like what is a boy rap borat it's
a borat bull rat what is it yeah is that
the scene where you guys were at the
dinner party he went to the bathroom and
brought the [ __ ] back in a plastic bag
i didn't do that i was but he did he
brought it back right and the people at
the table didn't know
they didn't know that this guy was it
was real [ __ ] it was uh it was one of
our crew members [ __ ]
it was real yo i'm telling you that's
commitment and in a place like that like
that guy g week whatever the [ __ ]
so now you guys if you i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna watch it you gotta watch
it you can't take it
you will laugh at your friends [ __ ] it
it took over the whole world by storm i
mean and the thing about comedy in that
way is that first you have to have a guy
who's good enough to [ __ ] never break
character
to never be like he wore the same suit
come in it was a whole movie yeah the
way he started stinking he never broke
european
he never broke and
the reaction of
it's hard to explain babe
and let me tell you something i'm in a
[ __ ] right
you got
about six months ago
about four minutes and i was like oh my
god i can't i can't even
it's wow
it's [ __ ] wild i don't know but you
know what it really was about
exposing the racism in people when they
think that nobody's watching that's
right and boy did they
that's right he could you could get
booyah
you could get that you could get people
to be
open open and
the other phenomenon about the movie is
that
they only had them
out of all the people in that movie they
only had to pay five people because
everybody else signed a release even
they didn't know and when it came out
they got mad but people are camera
[ __ ]
yeah and they all they shoot them and
they say you want to sign this release
gonna be for this documentary then they
sign it well we don't have to pay you
now [ __ ] and so only five people i paid
we made so
much
money so when you were in those when you
were in those scenes were you free to
talk at any time you wanted to or would
they just say hang back and react
well the only things i was in was the
ones i talked in
the one writing the ball
yeah you know but the [ __ ] there's a lot
of [ __ ] that didn't make the movie like
me and borat
kissed
a
lot but that didn't make the movie
and then
in the spec uh
you know how dvds have the special
features i don't know if they have
special features when you stream stuff
maybe if it says it right rarely
so there was a special
feature on the dvd for a lot of you
borat experts out there that have it
pull it back out and the special feature
was we were doing like a reenactment of
running down the beach for like baywatch
because remember pam anderson yeah
so now you got
me
running down the beach in a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
watch [ __ ]
oh yeah you got ken davidian running
down there and one his fat shit's flying
every goddamn way and then you got of
course sasha with that long thong thing
that he wore the green one
and then i had to go out into the water
and we had water experts this far out
came with me i had to go underwater and
come up like
yeah like it's amazing like pam anderson
but that [ __ ] oh my god wait a minute
where's my glasses this is the the borat
phone right here cheese are you are you
familiar with the concept even of of
boring i just remember he was at the
academy awards
uh he came out in character i believe he
was there yeah but tell him what this
[ __ ] is about yeah so um so at the time
no one knew if it was a real documentary
or what but basically sasha baron cohen
is the actor here and he went undercover
as this character named borat who was
allegedly from
kazakhstan thank you
and the whole thing he was like acting
like he was filming his trip to america
and what he would do was just this
insane things like for example he'd you
go to the bathroom put his [ __ ] in a bag
come back out and be like oh i'm from a
different culture in front of trump
tower don't leave that out oh he did all
sorts of [ __ ] like on things that were
felt unspeakable at the time and so and
the whole thing he's trying to like find
a wife and his who's he in love with
he's in love with pam anderson anderson
right hence the baywatch thing so right
it's it's all about his like travels
across america
just like that he wears that thing like
if he was wearing a three-piece suit
yeah he got a lot of balls but the thing
about it he didn't ask you to do nothing
that he wouldn't do right it wasn't like
he's playing you and just making you do
stupid [ __ ] and he don't have to but
there's a freedom of being in that
[ __ ] space that not a lot of guys
would [ __ ] do that and stay in
character
and
see the uncomfortableness in people
and and he that's where you guys worked
in that area were like listen the the
racists that were in this movie they
didn't come from central casting they
were [ __ ] bona fide successionist
racists and never had a black person
come to their front door so when i
showed up like you know dressed like a
hooker cowboy had stiletto [ __ ]
heels and a jean calvin klein jean skirt
and a pink bra and some leopard [ __ ]
they're like what the [ __ ] but that's
because he hit it listen and but you
couldn't do a second take because once
you do it that's it yeah yeah that's it
you got to go to another town and set up
another family and tell them there's a
dignitary and another thing okay so we
uh
during the special features me and boya
was up on a um
uh
uh lifeguard thing and he's hitting it
from the back and [ __ ] but the thing is
that even when i was in the water and i
was up there i was on the [ __ ] rag
and i had to [ __ ] i thought the
sharks were gonna come eat my legs off
when i was in the water my [ __ ] pad's
going to flip sideways because
jesus [ __ ] christ what am i doing you
know
and let me see what our kendavidian and
him ran through that business meeting
but naked true did it man
did it and um
yeah there was this you know i did have
a cow milking machine hooked to my titty
oh my goodness
i mean
man i should be getting some big big
bucks in this [ __ ] because i
feel like i'm the girl they call when
they say you know we really need at this
point in the movie we need somebody to
jump off the roof into a vaticello who
are we going to call gabrielle no no she
ain't going to do it we're called taraji
no no she wanted too much got that money
because i know i know who [ __ ] let's
call lenelle i feel like i'm that [ __ ]
in hollywood
yeah
because i'll [ __ ] do it
you don't you don't care
that was it's it it
it got nominated for an account nominee
for that did you go to academy awards no
they didn't find my hooker ass and i
went to the golden globes because that's
when you can get drunk and parties
that's the party
well i got so [ __ ] wasted the golden
glows i started crying cause boy boy i
did win the golden glove i didn't win
[ __ ] you just thought i want some child
like it was [ __ ] fantastic
i was so drunk
but you know it it's [ __ ] it was
great i mean it was great one of the
ones we went i wasn't there something
about he was walk i remember seeing him
walking over instead of walking down the
aisle
he was climbing over over seats
boy that's probably in the black church
maybe that was in the black shirt
remember in the black church you went to
the black shirt yeah
a little child you know then they had
the frat boys there was
the frat boys that were drinking calves
racist ass frat boys
they was all saying this [ __ ] and
they're like yeah we'll [ __ ] sign the
release then the [ __ ] come out and
they're like [ __ ] we didn't know
misunderstood and people were trying to
sue boy boy that's a fictitious
character did so good luck with that
please you don't have the money changed
it changed
so you know what i'm saying i mean he
had money when he came in the game but
he made so much money who would you
compare him to because you know he's
elusive like nobody doesn't really do
much
because he's
[ __ ] brilliant dude man yeah he's
brilliant maybe andy uh kaufman yeah wow
like that i missed me some um
sam kennedy was my mother
did you know sam kennedy i didn't i wish
i always felt like i would i was hanging
around the comedy store but i didn't uh
you don't see fat tuesday i i haven't
seen it but i knew some cancer you got
to see it tell the people working the
people watch it it's on streaming now
right yes it's on amazon prime but is it
about the the the
lawlessness of fat tuesday or is it
about what comedians went through there
well what lawlessness it was did they
throw a chair at somebody
well
that could happen in your local bowling
alley i mean goddamn i don't know i
don't remember i mean that was that
wasn't what the document was focusing on
the document was focusing on the fact
that guy tori started this night in the
belly room the [ __ ] took off he went to
the main room and and it was the place
to be
every [ __ ] honor off night tuesday
night for a year
and that
you know you got all these good black
comics down in the bar and south of 10
freeway anybody come and see but now we
got a place on [ __ ]
sunset boulevard the comedy store right
the comedy store yeah the [ __ ]
comment store so then you know now we
got our names on the wall
my name is on the wall now my name is
another one over there it's not
mine is i started i started over there
in 79 but you know
your name deserves to be on the wall
over there mine does not yes it does i
don't even work the comedy store so so i
didn't work it but i worked fat tuesday
what uh
how no i need your listeners to
vote on whether george and i should be a
power couple
power couple in the comedy industry i
heard that you were married well i am
sort of
all right
sort of i'm not but no but
you go to deep dive okay so i got
married
and then i married somebody in 90 days
i'm going to say that nobody
you don't have to talk about it i'm
going to say that nobody's talking about
the rapes why the [ __ ] i'm uh
but do you grab dicks or does it always
feel like you might grab somebody's dick
i don't grab anybody's dick but it
always feels like when we when we were
kissing this [ __ ] and drinking i always
felt i felt like you might i did not
grab your dick though no but i you
wanted me to try to put it out there we
could still do that
you know what the way it looks today you
wouldn't find it on the first ground
you have to look around for your keys
you know you're like i just did a whole
you're compact before you find my dick
in the back
that thing is going
i'm not sure i'm not sure where it's
going
it's almost like would you see a tree
and go [ __ ] that tree is getting
how can a tree get smaller over that's
why we'd be perfect because i don't you
know i mean you know but see here's the
thing even if you have a small peanut
y'all still won't head though so what's
that all about
what do women get some more
what do women think what do women think
when
when a guy has a small dick
do they think like this
because you know if you're trying to
make a first impression there's no more
first impression more
more [ __ ] well i tell you they're
having a small dick if you're like if
you lay it on your wallet it gets bigger
but you know
i mean
that's what i used to say just say you
got to trim the hairs to make the i'm
good
to make to make the house look bigger
you know what the house store the house
ain't going to look big if
all the
shrubs
are all women some women might be very
so excited to have a small addict man i
think some dudes you know some dudes
have there's that big dicks and some
dudes my grandmother used to say there's
a top for every pot
so there's a whole there's a
there's a woman out there there's
people out there yeah but is it a pot to
make a stew or a pot to boil an egg
what size [ __ ] pot
what size pot you know
wow
that that's going to take some time can
a dude have a uh an attractive dick like
a dick that looks good
you're saying one day you seen them okay
cause sometimes the girls say that oh he
had the more yeah well okay if addicted
to a female to look good first of all it
should be straight okay the curvers
you know but you gotta have a lot of
dick to have a curve in it because you
know people have got that's nice
wait a minute i got a [ __ ] if you go
down the street yesterday this
[ __ ] came out the hair in time
really bro like do you want me to repost
this
[Laughter]
but it should be straight and it should
be uh it doesn't matter whether it's got
for me whether it's got hair around it
or not we don't need a bush but a man
you know i don't need a man spending too
much time in the mirror [ __ ] shaving
his dick you know what i'm saying just
like you can have that or you cannot
have that just nice in the middle
grooming is nice scissors
scissors landscaping they say mental
but it don't have to be all that you
know debilatories and all that [ __ ]
cause who you trying to impress and then
you know it should be have this should
be circumcised for me just saying
you know and then you should have nice
nice
head
and a couple of veins you know just
versus blank
well girth is good and length is good
earth handling is very good
i think griffin
[Laughter]
that's what i'm doing i'm supposed to be
going out there to eat i never got a
chance to let's go
dad you can look at the cheapest date i
am you can take me to your own [ __ ]
restaurant
not crustaceans and all you can take me
to your own restaurant i'll be happy
dave
all right
okay but if we go to crustacean i have
to go trim my hair not full bush but you
know nice i know you want me to suck
your dick cause you take me to
crustaceans no
you know i can buy my own i don't want
you to see it
and i'll still take you down i don't
want to see it anyway
i don't i don't want to see it nobody
should see it
well i mean first of all if you're
digging you know you know all the better
for me you know all those carnivals they
used to have like the fact that it
stopped with the self-deprecation
arm out of his back that dude's still
out there somewhere nobody sees him i
saw the biggest dick i ever saw in my
entire life in miami the gay boys i was
on doing a play and we were on tour and
the gay boys dared me to [ __ ] him dude
like girl you gotta [ __ ] for me girl
girl this is back in the free [ __ ] days
you know
and i'm this [ __ ] was really
ugly too he's so [ __ ] ugly at this
gigantic ass dick so i you know made my
move all this was gonna [ __ ] i swear the
guy we got naked it was dark i thought i
had my hand on the motherfucker's knee
so like one of these cans here it was
like this much [ __ ] dick still i had
my like oh no i can't do this any no
thank you [ __ ] you gay boys
y'all can have it i don't know if it's
genetic or what happens but
same thing happen to you everything
though
but everything is about the pink the
size of the penis and guys in guys
you know
it is but see i already love you no
matter what size your penis is yeah i
know if i want to go get dick you know i
live my grandchild that's quick all
around me yeah
uh
as he as he pop right
what was your relationship no that's
cool what was your relationship with
prince
none
other than um
he had a big affiliation with oakland
i'm from oakland
you know did you ever meet him no
he had a i've been to his concert though
back at oakland college he was amazing
it was no but i've seen him when it was
vanity six the time and prince
that was back in there are you familiar
with that music
vanity six or prince or the time what
did you listen to baby sexy baby
temptation
uh where's my boy uh where's my boy the
dedication to uh
i love god
you're an art liberal fan i love it too
i wanna dedicate this to my man sleepy
always and forever i'll wait for you
when you come over in 25 years there you
go
he's the guy that invented the shout
outs
yeah i love
the beau i've been to the art of the bow
show too before survival yeah and it's
[ __ ] cranking do you know have you
seen purple rain
the movie yeah
no no the real actual no no no no no
in the video but no i i never saw okay i
wasn't a prince fan
oh my god at that time no no no just
wait a minute this is it's a good it's a
good it's a great this was in between
time he won an academy award yeah that
it was in between my time
i knew prince yeah
you know show enough prince tattoo and
some prince bling we got on here
uh you know the symbol you know the
symbol
is
really i mean what he did was brilliant
about changing his name to his cell he
got his rights until he got his rights
back um masters he was trying to get his
message so michael beard and i walked
him to his car
last week
at russell's wedding
when he did my talk show and prince
drove himself which he said george i
drove myself i was like prince drove
himself we go out there he's in a stutz
bearcat convertible
and every rim of his of his
car
the hub was that [ __ ] was that symbol
i had to chase him down and man i think
his [ __ ] gas pedal was that symbol
like it
was a trip to see him get in that car
and drive off by himself it's crazy and
i told beard there goes prince
you know that's bear cat going the wrong
way he was going the wrong way
oh did you talk about my baby he's
[ __ ] going the wrong way he was like
he was awesome man that dude was a real
he was a real i still can't i've heard
his music i hear it but i still have not
been able to play it yet it still hurts
too bad and then i got guilty because
i'm like okay michael i ain't forgot
about you neither baby you know so shout
out to michael jackson mike mike oh man
did you ever see michael jackson
perform
why does that music mean so much to you
is that the one
no it's a stutz bearcat okay
oh i like the little techie though he
was a [ __ ] awesome little man
oh yeah um he was funny i think
chappelle has his motorcycle purple rain
motorcycle yeah
that's still good i've seen it
there
in yellow springs
yeah
i think he's got
probably more than one you know you know
um
talk about hip and hip knee replacement
he had hip replacement surgery i know
wouldn't you you see how far you jump
out then speaking and high heels is a
miracle his little hips and snapping
half years before you jump off the piano
and end up in the splits so it just made
us so excited because he was copying
james brown back in the day
he was uh yeah man michael
james brown sam cook all that [ __ ] so
hip replacements occasionally
if you had it done you'd have to go in
there for a little bit of like
realignment or retuning like there's a
guy that's in a band i don't want to say
his name had hip replacement surgery had
to have a redone lost half an inch in
his leg because of a of a malpractice or
mal thing
but prince didn't go back to get it kind
of realigned and then it turned into
chronic
pain which which he took the pills for
people to quit fixing [ __ ] but they
don't realize if you're really gonna
do you know you should do if you if you
if you have reputable doctors you should
do
if you have reputable doctors let me say
that you should do as they instruct you
to do for the aftercare or you just you
have to do the after care you just kind
of you're trying to
get your car tuned up and just really
change the oil and not do the rest of it
so
so his vanity of himself
was
a cause for him not to go get re-tuned
yeah just like important looking for
donda yeah when had all that goddamn
surgery and then you know to try to look
and you know i'll be walking around i
wish i had and i have my little belly
that i have and i was i was watching uh
uh okay michelle's uh my killer body
last night about all these people whose
uh
butt injections and the [ __ ] done gone
wrong and they [ __ ] up and they're
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] them [ __ ] up all
you have to do is watch that for about
three episodes you'll be like oh [ __ ]
this i'm just going to deal with this
we're going to just deal with it because
if we didn't live in l.a we'd never even
be thinking about this [ __ ] did you ever
see michael jackson in person yeah
i was young though
i saw jackson five michael in person
okay
i saw him i testified in the trial in
2005
and i saw him in the in the courtroom
what makes somebody
who
looked the way he looked as a child
end up
looking the way he looked towards him
he looked like
well you know he had vitiligo right
that's that skin disease and blotchy
makeup can be blotchy
and i do remember i have seen his hands
with signs of that vitiligo and stuff
like that but then why didn't he make
the white parts darker instead of making
the dark parts lighter and while they go
get some little white ass kids yeah
don't nobody want to talk about the
weird [ __ ] about the j listen i love the
jacksonville little jacksonville i love
the whole [ __ ] family here icon you
did it first would nobody be doing no
none of this boys man none of this [ __ ]
everyone y'all y'all they laid it down
after temptations it was a [ __ ]
jackson probably wouldn't have been no
husbands none of that [ __ ] you're a
royalty i'd [ __ ] with you the long way
but
if your dad tells you have a big nose
like he had a big nose as a kid he had
acne and had acne
and
do you go that
i mean i had acne i mean
looked like the rest of the goddamn
family went to plastic surgery way too
and then you know why did everybody in
the family look like that look at look
at joseph and look at catherine i mean
catherine might have had a neptune
dancer but
you know why why what is all that about
i don't understand and then you know
my i made friends with jermaine for a
brief time in life and he took me to
haven hey yeah i haven't heard you and i
went to haven harrison it was really
great and it was really exciting and
really really great but then you know
you hear that hearing randy then share
the [ __ ] wife and the [ __ ] got
kids with both of them so their kids is
all brothers and sisters and first
cousins that's some country goddamn
that's some country [ __ ] right there
and and like jermaine and michael had
they had real beef like siblings yeah
because
the lead singer before michael last
hopped on on the scene it was everybody
was screaming for jermaine and michael
would say i love all my brothers
including jermaine that's what he would
say
i thought he would say in public so so
so if you think about like let's think
about back in the
uh
60s where your dad
gets you in the car with all your
brothers he worked he worked nights or
work during the day and all of a sudden
he's got you practicing and whipping
your ass if you don't if you don't spin
the right way and then you get in the
car and you start to go to these
nightclubs which they used to have and
have contests and stuff and you start
winning the contests
and you're you're a
failed musician and now you have these
kids and then you're taking them
everywhere and they're starting to get
they're [ __ ] winning because they're
amazing the richard it's the richer king
richard syndrome yeah king richard did
the same thing with his kid well listen
here's the thing that kills me okay so
you got all these kids how you know all
of them can dance and all of them can
say did you beat that into all of them
and some of them was popular and some of
them wasn't you know randy the only
reason by saying his goddamn name right
now is because he co-executive
of the janet uh documentary that just
came out and everybody think about randy
was his last hit what was it i'll wait
yeah you know jermaine had some hits
jermaine got his he's got hits you got
let's get sick
i mean
hits like michael jackson forget about
me that's that's ridiculous his thing
but
no jermaine was the man jermaine got a
career jermaine got got hits but if you
if you're talking about
two brothers who are one's the youngest
one the youngest one becomes the lead
singer and you're used to being the guy
and you're not the guy i don't give a
[ __ ]
you're gonna you're gonna have
you're gonna have beef
there
and
you know uh
as a michael jackson historian yes
um
they only
[Music]
they only you know that right before the
night before 9 11 at a concert in
madison square gardens and that was well
maybe the last time he performed it was
all of them all of them and they charged
him to go they charged his brother like
250 000 500 000 to go he gave his mom
and his brothers like he paid them to go
well
i mean they performed but they made like
i'll re
low figure 250 thousand dollars for
showing up okay well you know what
sometimes you pay somebody just to get
them off your [ __ ] dick you know what
i'm saying like i'm gonna get these
[ __ ] in mind they don't know
i'm not [ __ ] with them no more
you know maybe yeah but then you know if
you're not going to pay your brothers
and sisters and they can do the job why
pay somebody else i never understood why
he didn't have the jackson jewish
background on his albums and then use
other people when you go out on the road
or something or you know whatever i
don't know because their voice has been
together since they was sure babies you
know like just like being a twin or
something like that
so
would you have bought neverland ranch
i think that
two things i think that happened to him
first the one thing is when he burned
himself when he lit his head on fire
his whole life was over set on fire when
they laid his head on fire
in the can and the director said let's
do it one more time
and
that guy hit the switch early
which you wouldn't even you wouldn't
even put a performer in that kind of
situation
pyro
[ __ ] jerry crow lit up got to the bar
he had the whole friar tuck thing but i
think that was the beginning of
his life yeah of the end because of the
nerve endings in his head and yeah and
the pills and the pills and when you
started doing the pills yeah and the um
accomplices
and the accomplishments you can't do
nothing by yourself r kelly like you
burn your [ __ ] head man and you're
just like you gotta take some [ __ ]
food it's your scalp you know how
delicate have you ever had a perm joist
oh i dyed my hair blonde and my [ __ ]
head was on fire
the guy the guy goes i'll come right
back and i was up there and i was going
[ __ ]
like if it's sizzled
like when you're going like this
and he's like what's the matter i go
my [ __ ] head is hey man you got to
say something i said [ __ ] you
got to tell me
before you leave say hey if your head's
burning let me know because you know i
might have put too much but i stayed
quiet someone in my someone in my head
didn't blow like a [ __ ] dandelion
you're lucky you got a head of hair now
that came back yeah
so have you been enjoying doing this oh
my god
oh my god um the the podcast is good
yeah you glad to be back in the studio
did we do it during the pandemic yeah oh
yeah we started with the people you
stayed in here yep
he's a rebel that george no i got gail
gill came in you know gil was a
detective with the sheriffs
remember that yeah
and night stalker you know
so we're we're
[Laughter]
i mean i'd rather show them than tell
them
i think just saying
you know you know you know angela davis
right the the
black activist
i wish i knew him my grandmother was
afraid of angela davis
out from watching the news when we were
in the 70s
this is going to be some reason and i
would say grandmother and i would say
you want me to call angela davis i'll do
it i would say grandma paint the garage
paint the [ __ ] garage that's your job
want me to call angela davis where's the
roller coaster
she was scared to angela davis
she's a [ __ ] g she's being a
professor in san francisco that's right
she's angela davis if you're out there
i would love to i would love for angela
davis to be on the podcast
i'll come in for that i'll be yours i
would love to talk to you right over
that corner y'all won't even know i'm
here except for what i'm eating i'll
know
like i do i look in the corner i know
you're the only one
george
you could take it you can't be you have
to have him on the side as soon as he
laughs everybody look over
[Laughter]
so we're going on a date you're going to
take me to your restaurant what did paul
what it explained except
explain paul mooney to people who have
never maybe heard of paul money
i think paul mooney
is truly one of the greatest comedians
when you say when you do see fat tuesday
you'll see me talking about he was
did you ever see paul money perform yeah
this dude was like
everybody talks about richard pryor they
wrote a lot together but paul mooney was
very very special as a comedian man and
very smart
the thing somebody i didn't know
until i started really going to the deep
dive studying him because you know marco
we're all from oakland yeah paul came
from oakland too
a lot of his life he lived in oakland
died in oakland and um
i'm going to send you his album right
now
uh paul mooney's album i want you to
listen to this i listen race have you
listened to race that's my favorite i i
all i ever do in my car now is listen to
comedy the comedy
and i listen to kevin harris yes
and kevin hart had a lot of paul mooney
on there i'm not sure why paul mooney
didn't win
a grammy for race
well hell snoop's never even won a
grammy yeah so
[ __ ] the grammys when it comes to that
did you see the uh uh super bowl
halftime show i absolutely did and you
know people were talking about uh those
guys being old like you know
they say that [ __ ] is disrespectful
uh
you know it
it's just like how can you be a legend
50 of the people loved it thought it was
out of sight 50 of the people complained
about it
well the thing is that to see snoop quip
walk you know that was beautiful that
was awesome
snoop was awesome
snoop was [ __ ] he killed it they all
did but
dre he's a presence amazing eminem
didn't [ __ ] off amazing
[ __ ] mary j blige's queen of
hip hip hop that was amazing and let's
not forget the neighborhood
kendrick lamar
and kendrick lamar nobody talk about
kenneth lamar
i just did
yeah
yeah
yeah it was so inglewood it was so west
coast so like like they haven't even had
a guy you know we come from
the source awards and [ __ ] like that we
remember [ __ ] like that in source
magazine but they haven't they haven't
had compilation like that they're just
starting to do them like i think like
e42 showing you know the bay area
gay area
is there doing a lot of compilation
stuff like that
can we talk about
jazz
black artists
rock and roll
black artist
funk
black artist
rap
black artist
rap black artist reggae black artist
the jazz
documentary ken burns
country there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of
musical charlie pride just left us
charlie pride was
the goat
was amazing
a black man singing country come on they
probably had nooses hanging in his yard
every [ __ ] way he went
and he did it you know this halftime
show my kids who could give a [ __ ] less
about football could not wait for the
halftime show
to come on it was amazing you know a lot
of people were saying it's the best one
it's the best one recently for sure
because you know i i will not
uh discount prince's halftime show i
will not in the red count in the rain i
will not discount beyonce and bruno
[ __ ] mars either
and um
you know and then michael did one too
well janet and justin minus the titty i
was i was at the rose bowl when michael
jackson did it
in 93 he was amazing amazing
i was at bruno mars and beyonce
up in that bay area yay area
some weather weather woman some old
[ __ ]
some old finances had so much more fun
with me i probably would have and then
uh
but
it was very special to have it
in l.a yeah to see those guys not just
in l.a like fluffy's about to do dodgers
stadium god bless but not at dodger
stadium and englewood where they even
built had the audacity to build the
newest most
state-of-the-art stadium ever in england
hopefully there'll be more jobs for
people of ingerwood i think that was one
of the or stipulations of of when they
built it there was they had to employ
people from englewood like first or at
least give them a chance that's right
in that halftime show in the structure
they built for the halftime show yeah
they even showed tams
tams oh yeah
well they got a tabs on uh you know
burgers right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i saw
that that was crazy that's for every
coffee and then you had his mom's
[Music]
let's talk about nipsey hustle
very close
no you know in proximity but not in
physicality
i never met nip i have since
met his mom and his grandmother and
his brother
and sister
but
i never met nip my whole you know he was
a great guy i always wish you know i
wish i knew whether tupac knew me or
liked me or nip knew me like me his
music my daughter is of that age i knew
about nip before because i do live in
the world in the 60s
yeah you know and of course you hear you
know slots and boy and all all his
stuff on the street and um i had been
into the marathon shop and supported i
have bought shirts and stuff and the
stuff that i have now at the house is
authentic it came from the marathon shop
i paid 100 for the gold vape you know
202 things so i supported when i didn't
even know how much my support meant you
know but the tragedy of that
it's just like if you live through i'm
old enough to have lived through
uh kennedy kennedy king
i think malcolm
um
park big yeah and you think that you're
the assassination era is over but guess
what
no
but you know those guys those guys have
created a business where
it was almost like the gangsters in the
30s where al capone would go with people
or john dillinger was out there and
gangsters were out there living the
mafia in new york they didn't go by
themselves and rappers have built a
business where
they need to protect themselves 24 hours
a day yeah it's just like when you you
know you never get got until you get
caught slipping
and it's like
if you go to the if you live someplace
for 13 years and the market is right on
the corner and you always go and unlock
your door and go to the market then one
year you just say i'm just going to muck
i'm not going to let my door now you
come back your house is cleaned out
cause you got cars slipping you can
never let your guard down like that when
you get to a certain level like that
it's a shame that that is true because
he you would have thought that he had
enough love in the community that he
served right to not be took out right in
his [ __ ] front door
but
his family and doing a good deed
put something up on instagram and
you know you're not supposed to put it
up
where you are in the moment right
people are learning because he was at
his pad somebody recognized where he
lived went over there yeah and got him
yeah yeah yeah you don't do that i was i
always late post all the time i do i do
lives
live
but like i'll say i'm in georgia well
you never know where the [ __ ] we are you
know even if i said this city i mean
we're in the house you know what i mean
so um have you ever met anybody that's
creepy out there like after shows and
stuff i have
creepy or anybody that's followed you
back to the hotel or no i was just
invading your space yesterday i have
never i think i don't know i'm maybe
because they know i do have a big mouth
and i am a teller or maybe because i
just command [ __ ] respect on
mine but never in once in the history of
my career have anybody ever came at me
sideways and wanted to like [ __ ] in lieu
of doing something for me that's never
happened to me yeah you know maybe i
wouldn't what they were looking for and
thank god for that
i already had my chair
i think so what do you what do you think
that monique made
made her mistake in their handling your
career you know you know you ever say
yes do you see precious
you
yes
you're afraid to [ __ ] say no because
we told you all the other movies
yeah
and i love you last movie we went
through the apollo 13. i only watched
the last movie movies with good america
was the ten commandments that was the
last one
but you know i i think that there's
you know
uh
influence or fame can be
very
much of a drug that's hard to maintain
people sometimes
and
you know for such an incredible
performance and to win an academy award
and everything after that i personally
i think she's great
has been a mistake like every move that
she's made after winning an academy
award i'm sure
she wouldn't consider her mistakes but
if you look at somebody handling the
career after winning an academy award it
seemed to be
more of an attack career than
than what's my next project career you
think
i'll have no comment on that subject
right there
amen
because what i do well good because it's
not going to be it's not going to come
out in the [ __ ] house but i do think
i talked to her about directly
you know
because um
there's no way to win
if you comment because there's people
that are going to be like you're
absolutely [ __ ] right there's kind of
people like [ __ ] you money gets a legend
and you know what i think i i have
already probably posted on my social
media and have spoken her about and that
is that and that is that yeah good
but
it it's what you do it's an influence
you need snacks in your studio george
because i smoked
massive amounts of marijuana before i
got here and had an edible and i had to
eat airline almonds and like plastic
that's what i knew those were airlines
we do have some snacks back there what's
next i can we could grab you something
we're almost done anyway
you don't know you can feast when we're
gone no go go get em go bring them okay
let's see what you're trying to see if
she's trying to see she's all right
though
i really but let me say this to you to
the people who are listening or watching
george lopez has been a very good friend
to me
because in all my career i've never had
a show of my own never been a regular on
the show always you know coming from the
theater i always wanted to get that
family feel you know your parking space
and see everybody and what's it like to
work on the show for seven and eight
seasons and stuff like that or even that
works
on that great late night show that you
had you know
um
and you to have me on your show you know
like seven episodes or something like
that that was really really awesome and
i really enjoyed kicking it with i think
that's a show that nobody's really
watched it's kind of like my own curb
your enthusiasm the locals tv land show
you seen that one
is that the you could say no no no was
that the regular journal with you and
uh
constance cotson no i did one for fx
that's
okay i think like 24 episodes no then
the one with constance i loved it i
didn't see it everybody did nobody saw
the one that i did for tv land right and
there was some you did i saw you and i
said i was going to write you a part i
was going to put you in and i did you
did it and we had a great time doing i
had a great time every day
never you were [ __ ] great you were
you were amazing to have let me do that
so what what would i make you a t i made
you a teacher that had
me and me and citrix patrick
were you were a teacher and nobodies
but you were a teacher and what did i
make your teacher of like
english wasn't it math english english
history
i thing was the history i had to do
something about time
and then you i mean your character was
what's great man we were smooching and
[ __ ]
you had me and you had me and citrix and
moochie
we did a scene where i drove him back to
school and he was all nervous because
the kids were making fun of they were
bullying them and i said don't worry
about that but she was helping him being
bullied and then i said there's mrs
fernandez i'm not 13 listen for that i'm
not 13 anymore
you know
uh but it was it was it was a good uh it
was a fun show i watched abbott
elementary that's just as funny as
abbott elementary school
ooh that [ __ ] is fun what does that mean
what is that show it's about a school
and it's part of a crazy principal and
the teachers that worked at this really
low budge school
and um
i forgot her name was sean to scientists
anyway but um
um it's a very multicultural and a young
guy who used to be on everybody hates
chris is on it and it's really good show
it's just really funny quirky you know
like like you said like herb quirky did
you ever have any teachers that you
would have [ __ ] yeah i would have
[ __ ] my teacher mr baldo he was my
math teacher
and he looked like um
the courtship he's fought he looked like
billy bixby with his tight pants you
know bixby used to wait a little taipei
and i
really wanted to give it to mr baldwin
and then i did [ __ ] one of my art
teachers
[Laughter]
yeah i remember his name but i can't say
it now because i don't want him to get
in trouble um
i would have [ __ ] my fourth grade
teacher mrs rudorfer were your daughter
you know how i rooted out
yo she had some look like two [ __ ]
cherry
tomatoes on the end of her tits
like she had big nipples or something
are you a big nipple fan
in fourth grade i was
and she used to wear those bras that
were like cones and you could see
through them sometimes
what was that 1945 the [ __ ] on you yeah
that program that you're talking about
that abby stuff they just had uh last
week
they had happy [ __ ] abbott
abbott elementary abbott elementary they
they had uh i don't think we should let
old people [ __ ] get names wrong
because they're not going to learn if
you just don't say anything
i don't i don't say [ __ ] right
abbott abbott elementary
the star the young teacher that scared
me i didn't
her teacher
she based the whole program on her
teacher you know
yeah and
last week they actually showed they
brought the t-shirt her together and she
had no idea there was tears and
everything together
on the show no it was on the news
separately oh
it was a news piece and the teacher
still looks good
is that you yeah i wonder what mr baldo
looks like
i wonder what miss rudorfer looks like
and then the dude mr millett was [ __ ]
her and we didn't like him
because because we were trying to go in
elementary cast we would try to go in
after lunch and [ __ ] millet would
come out of there with lipstick on his
[ __ ] coffee [ __ ]
like man what school jordan daymond
sanford elementary
school room 23 and 24. oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and we hated him after that he was like
he was like he looked like uh
like a young like a
like a [ __ ] kenny loggins
[ __ ] with hair and [ __ ] i went
back in the
my grandson was going to school i saw
one of the teachers at the high school
he was going to
and she was hot
and i told my grandson if you ever get
some of that if you if you rat i'll kick
your ass that was she was hot i was on
the line of playing baseball at night
and said go go talk to your teacher and
i tried to convince the teacher to to
let me pass
and then i said i'll suck your dick and
he still said no
well you know what
mr ressa big second is not got the value
that it used to because i'm gonna tell
you something stick something could get
you some tires before no right maybe get
a whole car my car broke down
and like needles or someplace driving to
vegas
years and years and years ago my kid was
like four she was in the back seat
[ __ ] engine exploded i bought the
[ __ ] car from an auction anyway you
know and trying to run a little piece of
[ __ ] air conditioning drive through
there and a car blew up and so [ __ ]
the cops come
i said well i heard
you want to call tow truck yeah tow
truck i come and we had just passed the
time so i could see the time back to
something like how much is it to go take
me back to town he says 90 dollars i'm
like 90 dollars i don't have a [ __ ]
90 i said listen when i suck your dick
though and you're not a [ __ ]
said no
well he wanted the money
well i'm telling you the musical i mean
i got all of you i had to do it three
times
not one sucked for nothing
you're gonna get out three times
but you know it used to be a currency
dick and [ __ ] with some currency yeah
why like if you if like all the you know
not all of them but some porn you watch
and the landlord goes in there and he's
like
you're just behind me and then they'd be
sucking
yeah those were fine
you know those doctors did you hear what
they said about linda lovelace yeah oh
what'd they say tell me okay were you a
fan of linda lovely well a fan of the
movie what's that be a deep throat yeah
but you but you know if you look at
somebody john holmes
i saw john holmes eating ice cream at
pharaoh's
with his daughter i think i thought it
was his daughter
that [ __ ] i couldn't stop like
i saw lanell eating an ice cream mature
edger
well i mean is that john holmes over
here
yeah um
yeah poor linda lovelace she got the bat
yeah bad end of the stick
and they murdered each other some [ __ ]
like that they got murdered mitchell
brothers mitchell brothers mitchell
brothers in san francisco
they had you know big premier party with
linda lovelace you know what i went to i
went i was working at a san francisco
punch line in the 90s and there was a
woman
girl in the front row and she was
as beautiful as anybody i've ever seen
me she looked as good as me as beautiful
as you and she i brought her up on stage
we did a shout out tequila and she was a
stripper at mitchell brothers
and i was like hey i'll call you those
[ __ ] man
every phone call is eleven hundred
dollars no thanks oh yeah
but i mean
they were
and then what is that would you make a
movie about those guys yeah and i think
there's a special coming on soon too and
the mitchell brothers were it was
scandalous there's gangsters
but the hugh hefner thing do you think
the hue after things making as big a
splash as it should after seven episodes
like it's so much [ __ ] that i got to
catch up on
rat and
the playboy thing is big because
playboy's been
such a part of ours where's christy
hefner now where's christy hefner what's
she doing
but there's a lot more people that
be coming out if all of that well listen
that nobody so okay
but
everybody had accomplices remember i was
saying earlier [ __ ] okay so r kelly
shouldn't be the only one locked up if
you got grown ass men are taking little
[ __ ] to the airport and putting them
on planes and stuff like this and
picking them up and delivering them to
[ __ ] and stuff like that they
should go down too somebody had a house
everybody don't know their names and all
that or whatever everybody ain't talking
i don't know but all the [ __ ]
should go down and the business too
the girls too hindsight yeah
just like i'm not gonna mention a name
but i can't [ __ ] remember name what
kind of [ __ ] podcast you can't say
names well no no i don't you know
the guy that the guy that allegedly
committed suicide
in the joint and epstein's absolutely he
knew the name and he had the uh girls he
had that lady that just got convicted
shaleen maxwell running
the girls up there at home hey you're
going to love this right here
you put some of my [ __ ] up your nose i
used two fingers man you goddamn did you
give me the [ __ ] of what
that is used i used the same i used two
fingers only one i didn't double that i
didn't double dip i put on both sides
oh
yeah
i gave it to i gave it to the guys in
chicago they're they're
they're subscribed the musicians it's
great that's what i [ __ ] saw on the
plane what's the last movie you saw on
the plane
what are you doing what's the last movie
you saw in playing what's the last movie
you saw oh
[Music]
god damn what this stuff is
batman i think batman
what what did you see
the many saints of newark oh did you
like it
yeah i like gangster [ __ ]
yeah like that [ __ ] rayleigh and
what's that good fellows oh my god
good fellows and casino and of course
the godfather one
how come joe pesci wasn't in the
godfather that was before his time
where's joe pesci joe pastor we love you
over here and oh my god yeah
he's up i gotta get him to come to the
wheat party oh oh please if you get me
in the room with pesci i think he would
i think he would annoy him he seems like
he don't want him
i think i could get him to listen i got
all those other people coming to wheat
party i should be able to get him i want
to come and piss you who's your brother
i want to come and place you john you
know i love you thank you for coming by
i want to thank you guys for listening
to me and george and everybody uh said i
think it was enjoyable i think it was
enjoyable it was a lot
we shared a lot where does this play at
which i appreciate it uh this will be
every podcast platform and it comes out
on our youtube channel as well you're
not trying to get retribution or
anything for all those for that
no
for black women hell justin for brianna
who the
retribution
retribution
all right
but i will kill the [ __ ] if i
find him
i only remember one and i'm gonna take
you to go to my restaurant okay yes okay
you heard that three times people and
you've been watching oh my god
oh my god
you